the three main areas where we see room
for progress
first
nato russia relations
russia has cut diplomatic ties with nato
which makes our dialogue more difficult
so we should re-establish our respective
offices in moscow and in brussels
we should also make full use of our
existing military to military challenge
of communications
to promote transparency and reduce risks
and look also into setting up a civilian
hotline for emergency use
second european security including the
situation in and around ukraine
we are prepared to listen to russia's
concerns
real conversation on how to uphold and
strengthen the fundamental principles
security arrangements
russia should refrain from coercive
forceful strength aggressor rhetoric and
mainline activities directed against
allies
russia should also withdraw its forces
from ukraine
georgia and moldova
where they are deployed without these
countries
and all parties should engage
constructively in efforts to settle
conflicts including in the normandy
foreign
risk reduction transparency and arms
control
history has shown that engagement on
these issues can provide real
security
so we need practical measures that will
make a real difference
as the first step we are proposing
mutual briefings
on exercises and nuclear policies in the
nato-russia council
we should also modernize the vienna
document on military transparency
and work to reduce space
and cyber threats
we should consult on ways to prevent
incidents in the air and at sea
and we commit to full compliance
with international commitments on
chemical and biological weapons
finally we need to have a serious
conversation on arms control
including nuclear weapons and
ground-based intermediate and
short-range missiles
these areas represent an agenda for
meaningful dialogue and i have invited
allies andersha
to a series of meetings to address all
of these issues
in greater detail in the nato-russia
council
allies are ready to meet as soon as
possible
in all our efforts we will continue to
coordinate closely with ukraine
as well as with all the nato partners
including finland sweden
georgia and of course the european union
nato is a defensive alliance
and we do not seek confrontation
but we cannot and will not compromise on
the principles on which the security
of our alliance and security in europe
and of america
remain fully committed to our founding
treaty and our collective defense
strategy enshrined in article five
we will take all necessary missions to
defend and protect all allies
and with
thanks very much mr secretary general i
wonder if you can
tell us if there are any plans for
renewed talks for further diplomatic
talks
responses do you think will provide
more conversation the kind of
conversation to describe going forward
as we have invited uh i have as chairman
of the nato-russia council invited all
30 allies and russia
to a series of meetings where we are
ready to sit down and to have
substantive discussions on a wide range
of issues i mentioned the main issues in
the
nato written proposals we have
sent to russia today uh we also had to
sit down and listen to the russian
concerns
and we also strongly believe that
these issues represent topics where
we both can benefit
arms control
reducing the threats from nuclear
weapons from
short-range and
medium-range
missiles
addressing the threats and reducing the
threats from cyber space but also from
space
based weapon systems
more transparency
on military activities all of these
issues
represent in different ways
areas where actually
we can improve the security uh both for
nato allies and for russia
so at the end of the day this is about
whether it's a will
to engage in good faith and to try to
sit down and find a common ground
we will now go to nasa
from bloomberg
thanks so much for my question um i just
think that uh naval wants to keep an
open door policy with uh ukraine
um could it not in either these
responses are in responses going forward
to russia would nato consider um
in writing
saying that
ukraine is not on track for membership
anytime soon
um depending on the wording this
wouldn't necessarily close the door to
membership but it would simply state the
reality
is that we will not compromise on uh
some core principles and one of them is
of course that every nation has the
right to choose his own power
so nato
a country or a nation when they uh
decide to apply for nato membership
as for instance ukraine or when they
decide to not apply for
membership as
and uh and sweden have done so this is
about
respecting the right for
self-determination and then at the end
of the day the decisions on
membership will have to be made by
consensus
uh among the 30 allies and of course uh
the country that applies for a
membership and that is
that is uh developmental principles and
that is also of course reflected in the
nato positions
[Music]
hi thank you uh i want to ask about the
nato response force secretary general
can you um can you give us your
assessment over whether
uh you think that that is going to
actually be activated and when there's a
lot of talk here in the us that it could
be
activated in advance of some sort of
movement by russia as more of a
deterrent
um and then can you give us a sense
uh what do you think the ultimate size
could also could grow to the number of
troops and any special capabilities any
kind of insight into that okay
so we are now
reaching out to russia once again uh to
try to
pursue a path of dialogue and to define
a political solution that's the reason
why we
sent them this evening uh the
written proposals from 30 nato allies
covering
a wide range of different issues
but of course while we are uh hoping for
and working for
uh a good solution de-escalation
we're also prepared for the worst
and therefore
with our
efforts on the dialogue track we are
also
increasing the redness our forces
and nato allies have also increased
the presence uh including the black sea
and the baltic sea region with more
ships and more planes
partly to
conduct surveillance to monitor to have
the best possible picture of the
developments in in and around ukraine
but also to provide reassurance to
allies
and then part of that is that we
actually some weeks ago increased the
redness of the nato response force
this
response force is uh
it's composed of different uh elements
and the lead elements of the nato
response force
consists of
around 5000 troops
it's currently led by
france
but also other allies
contribute troops to
this lead element and it can be deployed
within days and then we have
additional follow-on troops that can
also be deployed on a short notice
and
to deploy the nato response force or any
element of the nato response force
we need a decision by
uh the north atlantic council by nato
uh
that decision will be made if necessary
and we will deploy if necessary
um
we
um we have plans in place that we can
activate and execute
on very short notice
uh so uh what we have done over there
over the last weeks is to increase
readiness and then what we've done over
the last years since russia used the
force against ukraine the last time
uh we um
we
have increased our presence in the
eastern part alliance with battle groups
in the baltic countries and poland
i welcome the u.s decision
to
assign
troops
on
high readiness and to the nato response
force
just demonstrating the very strong
commitment from the united states to
european security and demonstrating the
straight
strength of nato bringing nato allies
together and having a multinational
force like the nato
thank you very much uh good evening my
question is about the possibility for
ukraine and georgia to
join nato uh as nato
has said that there will be no
compromise on this
should we understand that the
decision of bucharest summit will not be
dismissed
uh as
of now
uh many politicians in ukraine and
georgia are using this statement
to show to its people that
that that their countries will become
members of nato
and european union very soon it was the
case for example in mind in 2014 don't
you feel that you are uh
getting wrong signal to those countries
thank you very much
we are standing by uh the core
principles uh on which european security
has been based for uh many uh
years for decades and that is that we
respect the
sovereign right of every nation to
choose what kind of security
arrangements
it won't be possible
or don't want to be
uh
that's the reason why we of course
respect
decisions by georgia and ukraine to
apply for membership and also
the reason why we have
engaged in a very strong and close
partnership with both these countries
our focus now is on reforms is to help
to
modernize and strengthen the defence and
securities institutions and to meet the
nato standards
but also why we respect decisions of
countries not to apply for membership
for instance
as finland and sweden but also with them
we have a very close partnership
politically
strong and close
consultations and also
our forces exercise together train
together and we have a achieved very
high degree of interoperability so this
is
this is this is about respecting nations
and their right to choose their own
paths
and
that has not changed that is actually
a principle that also russia has
subscribed to many times starting with
the helsinki final in
1975 but also the paris record in 1990
and many of the documents where this
principle has been clearly stated
we'll now go to thomas gucciker from uh
frankfurter algetong
thanks a lot secretary general
um my first question is is there
anything new
in your
in the answer that has been transmitted
to russia that did not come up when
russian
officials
were at nato for the nato last nato
russia council
and the second question there clearly is
the risk
that russia takes this written response
as a pretext
to
attack ukraine because it's
requests or have not been fulfilled
obviously
so why did you still decide
to reply in written form thanks
we decided to reply in a written form
because
we
take
uh it very seriously uh
the efforts to try to make progress
in our political dialogue with russia
and we have listened to russian concerns
we have listened also to the
russian
call for a written response
and i also think it's helpful
uh not only to meet in the nato russia
council as we did a couple of weeks ago
having an oral and open and
frank discussion on many of these issues
but also actually to go one step further
and to write down and agree among 30
allies
proposals
ideas topics
where we believe that it is possible to
make progress uh to uh find a way
forward uh and to
find uh
areas where we can actually agree
and that's the reason why we are
going to put all this into a written
document
um
[Music]
of course many of these positions and
views were also reflected in the
discussion we had in the nato russia
council but the fact that we now are
submitting a ridiculous document
uh provides us with the opportunity to
be
more specific to go more into the detail
and to be more concrete on everything
from how to reduce the risks from
missiles short-range uh range
range missiles reduce the
nuclear weapons arms control
to transparency
on military activities or cyber
plenty of room also for russia to see
benefits
reinforcing the security both for russia
and for nato alliance
and that's the reason we have conveyed
the proposals and that's the reason why
really hope that russia will
read through them
the proposals and the documents from
nato and from the united states
and then
be ready to
continue in further dialogue
there's no secret that we are far apart
and that there are some serious
differences between
nato
and
russia
but at the same time that makes it just
even more important that we uh look into
the proposal
in a reciprocal way
and try to identify the
political solutions where we can uh
agree uh to prevent
a new one
in europe which will of course be
extremely serious
and something we all have to
try to prevent
sorry thank you wanna and uh good
evening secretary general thank you for
allowing us to ask these questions
i've got to ask the question that i
asked you two weeks ago frankly
september are we closer
to war
with russia now than we were two weeks
ago considering development
also more troops not only in and around
ukraine but also now
belarus where russia
is in the process of deploying thousands
of combat troops
uh hundreds of aircraft
s 400 air defense systems
and a lot of other
very advanced capabilities
and uh this takes place under the
disguise exercise but it integrates very
much the russian forces and double
russian forces
and these are highly capable combat
troops and there is no transparency
on these deployments so of course this
adds to our concerns
it adds to the tensions
and
it shows that there is no de-escalation
on the contrary it's actually more
troops
more capabilities
in more countries
at the same time
that makes it just even more important
um hello secretary general about
applause radio um on the more
transparency on the military exercises
what do you mean by this do you envisage
the reduction of military exercises
because if you reduce exercises then
what you need to need the the forces for
uh for example and the second
thing is
do you have all allies on board because
in recent days
and agreed and uh
that we have now
uh that i have now on behalf of 30
allies
sent to sir
um
so
all allies are behind these positions
these proposals
also support
what i would call the dual track
approach
[Music]
it's not possible for me to go into the
specifics of each and every proposal
but what i can say is that
we have actually
proven before that
transparency on exercises
it can be very helpful
we have something called the document
which is agreed in the oc framework
and we strongly believe that we should
uh
invigorate that dialogue and the process
to try to modernize the documents
uh
observation inspection
of military
in exercises agreements
where snap exercises had not allowed it
for any kind of uh
inspection
and um
is illustrated as we speak
because with the
significantly increased russian
deployment
of combat 3d tubes in belarus
and aircraft and advanced
systems like s400
and of course that is exactly why we
need inspection and transparency on
exercises
because we have seen before we saw that
in crimea in 2014 you have seen it many
times before that exercises the high
redness of forces as part of an exercise
is used as a disguise
[Music]
would also help to reduce tensions and
preventatives
good evening to everybody mr secretary
general lincoln says that u.s offers
pass forward
in response to russian demands do you
really believe that it is possible where
we are talking about russia and second
question does a written reply sent to
russia includes the position of nato on
georgia's future membership
and the final point now do you think
that so far uh empty dialogue
gave uh aggressor the chance to occupy
and annex the neighbors thank you so
much
a political solution is still possible
but then of course russia has to engage
in good faith
to de-escalate and to sit down and
really
make a little effort to find a way
forward uh where we can find a solution
um
uh
i think it is important to also
understand that
we have proven before
it is possible
to
make agreement agreements with russia
that is of a mutual benefit both for
russia
we have decades of arms control which
has actually used the number of nuclear
weapons in europe
on the nato side with roughly
90 and and and banned uh uh
different types of uh nuclear weapons
and also limited
number of
strategic warheads in russia and the
united states
so arms control has been proven
before
and that's that's one of the reasons why
we
think it's important to really engage
once again in
in in real efforts to strengthen
the united states it can be agreements
in the oc it can be also things we agree
in different performances
it has to be balanced it has to be
reciprocal and it has to be of course
viable
and um and therefore
at the same time as we are
engaging in
a serious effort
to engage
with russia in a political effort in
political dialogue
we are also
stepping
consequences
and of course there's absolutely
security guarantees for all nato allies
and that's also reason why we're having
this version of the nato response
thank you anna for the floor uh mr
secretary general a while ago secretary
blinken told that whether russians
choose the path of diplomacy whether
they are
they choose the path of aggression
do you feel that we can still choose the
path of diplomacy or are you scared of
we are moving towards the path of uh
um of further escalation regarding the
fact that the united states states have
mentioned that clearly our favor of open
door policy that nato of course
is in favor of
that every nation has the right to
choose his own um
but for me that's not an argument
against dialogue for me that's um
or a foreign
where russia conceptually
decides to use force
and we are conveying a message
consequences
to use force to conduct aggressive
actions
against ukraine
and we are
and also increasing the readiness of our
nato response forces
thank you very much this concludes this
press conference from nato headquarters
good evening
you